la première guerre de l'information la
vraie guerre de l'information la
première guerre des réseaux sociaux et
moi j'ai toujours mon téléphone je
connaissais pas Twitter j'aime pas du
tout Twitter mais je passe maintenant
sur Twitter si vous n'êtes pas sur
Twitter vous savez pas ce qui se passe
et parce que vous savez pas ce qui se
passe vous pouvez pas répondre et on
nous demande une réponse instantanée à
tout ce qui se passe on vous le demande
à vous responsable politique et c'est
impossible de le faire la guerre c'est
du temps long c'est du recul il faut
prendre de la hauteur on peut pas être
dans la gestion de chaque événement en
instantané
première guerre des drones n'a rien à
balle ça c'est un sujet majeur
j'aimerais des questions je rappelle que
c'est la première étape la première
étape ce sont des engins pilotés par des
hommes à distance la deuxième étape à
laquelle on ne chappera pas ce sont des
engins qui avec l'intelligence
artificielle choisiront eux-mêmes leur
objectif on sera assez proche de la
notion de robot j'en parlerai on évitera
pas à la guerre des robots on peut se
rouler par terre on peut dire que c'est
pas possible que c'est pas bien que
c'est pas éthique mais c'est comme ça
que ça se passera parce que c'est comme
ça que nous adversaires feront la guerre
il faut savoir si on veut gagner la
guerre ou si on veut faire une guerre
électrique 100% voilà peut-être un débat
de réflexion
et puis dernier point sans attaquer
l'ennemi au sol c'est impossible de
gagner la guerre aujourd'hui il a
Ukrainiens je vous montrais dans les
planches ne n'attaque pas la Russie sur
le sol russe ils l'ont très peu attaqué
au début de la guerre dans quelques
sites de logistique ils ont créé
quelques frappes très limitées sur la
Crimée jamais avec des équipements
occidentaux et mis à part qui s'est
passé il y a deux jours avec des
équipements
Ukrainiens ils vont se frapper des bases
mais c'est évident que si pour gagner la
guerre pour que l'Ukraine gagne la
guerre contre la Russie il faut qu'elle
frappe le sol russe elle le frappera pas
sur le russe elle ne peut pas gagner la
guerre en Ukraine de la même manière que
la Russie ne peut pas gagner la guerre
en Ukraine non plus bon donc ça on en a
un peu sur la ensuite comment ça peut
évoluer mais pour des raisons
différentes on peut se concerne